ce 24 janvier l'heure est à
l'installation comme chaque année les
équipes de déclic théâtre investissent
les collèges saint quentinois
le match d'aujourd'hui c'est très
important de savoir c'est un match
amical on est bien d'accord
l'équipe qui gagne l'équipe qui perd on
s'en fiche
le collège gustave courbet attrape celui
des débuts de noureev chine luis plus
connu sous le nom de no no 92 mon
premier match d'impro et puis courbet
c'est aussi le collège ou ou aux baous
djamel notamment il ça on commence l
improvisation et puis plein d'autres qui
ne sont pas aujourd'hui des grandes
stars du showbiz mais en tout cas
beaucoup de comédiens ou de techniciens
même je pense à hocine à marion qui
étaient là avec nous on a tous une eau
pour beaucoup on a fait nos premiers pas
ici à courbon au sikkim itno joue
souvent larbitre celui qui donne les
thèmes et distribuer les pénalités le
méchant en apparence sympa à l'ecoute je
voyais toujours jamais il est gentil tu
quand on est quand on est sur scène
enfin il fait l arbitre qui est méchant
mais en vrai avec nous quand en dessous
la patinoire il nous donne des conseils
celui qui le découvre c'est le fondateur
de déclic théâtre papy lors d'un atelier
au collège ont dit non que t'es pas mal
faut inscrire le mercredi est inscrite
sur les ateliers du midi donc l'année
commencé moi je m'inscris pas je finis
mon module je suis mon année comme ça et
puis en cinquième j'ai retourné je
m'inscris le midi entre midi et deux
pour faire d'un pro mais très
sincèrement plus pour faire plaisir à
pas pipi les premières années où ils
s'estiment insignifiant puis un déclic
avec le départ des plus grands un goût
de faire rire de la scène rejoint par
une envie de transmettre papim dit un
atelier la croix du bois pour les jeunes
de voisins machin et utaka venir
ok donc moi je suis à l'heure et il y a
vingtaine de jeunes qui sont là et
papy ne vient pas un papy ou bien par
papy est pas là à l'heure prévue et au
bout de trois quarts d'heure papy qui
avait une galère sur la route papier
arrive et moi en fait je le regarde
jazzy c'est bon ils sont chauds dit non
non on continue donc je dis ah bon diop
a dit vas-y je te regarde
nono mène alors des ateliers s'occupe du
secteur improvisation il est aussi
directeur artistique des créations de la
troupe déclic et metteur en scène d'un
seul en selle le premier d'antoine rabot
lui aussi formé attrape un truc où tu
vois tu as un geste physique comme quand
on ferme les impros en quintet quoi tu
vois quelque chose qui vient pas
perturber par le déplacement le 2 mars
prochain antoine montera sur scène au
guichet montparnasse pour 1h
d'improvisation c'est un très grand
pédagogue de ce que je connais ça doit
être un des meilleurs profs d'un projet
j'ai pu avoir jusqu'à la m6 arbitre
responsable de l'improvisation comédien
metteur en scène nono multiplie les
casquettes avec toujours un objectif
transmettre son amour de la scène